hey my name is George and today at the
conference all the presenting on how to
integrate slap messaging app with the
Wolfram cloud and from date of it
hello everyone aim is George going to
view this I'm a graduate student at MIT
also studying material science and
condensed matter physics but unlike Kyla
I will not be talking about any of that
today hopefully I'll be trying to appeal
to a more general audience by talking
about how we can use the more for
language to script very easily some sort
of little apps on the slack messaging
system and some other sort of
productivity things okay the talk is
right before lunch I was told to wrap it
up early when that happened so we will
be doing that I think but feel free to
stop me and ask some questions okay okay
so have you guys used slack how many
people use slack in their amount of
curiosity okay perfect yeah I think it's
great as well so for those of you don't
know those slack is sort of a workspace
messaging app and it's nice because it
can integrate like a number of sort of
classical collaboration tools that we
require so for example it integrates
emailing scheduling anything do
conference calls with multiple people if
you're in a paid workstation definitely
like apparently it started off as this
searchable log of all conversation and
knowledge which I thought was a fun fact
and I'm sure everyone here at Wolfram
can relate that that's sort of a good
endeavor - yeah it has since taken on a
life of its own which we're gonna talk
about so the good thing about slack is
that in addition to being all of those
like sort of like it's personal chat
interface email the scheduling whatever
it could also it has a lot of built-in
apps and it has a command like line like
interface making it very easy to code if
you like some of your own apps so maybe
we should so this is sort of how a
typical slack workstation what look like
so here I have my three workstations
that I'm currently using in any
particular workstation there's different
channels it's quite clear that okay we
use our channel language and then you
can also directly message some users
this is my sort of personal space and
just to illustrate these
which is and these apps are for example
I there's this command line where I just
do slash and then these built-in
commands appear so for example by doing
this away is sort of toggle my status is
being away that's sort of a simple thing
I can then come back and say actually
I'm active I can also just use this to
type stuff like that okay so this is
sort of how the basic it's like user
interface works and the idea is that we
now want to come in and do sort of our
own slash commands that looks kind of
like this so this is for example one of
them sure I mean you're talking about
today okay so when this abstract was due
on sometime in July I hadn't I thought
this was a cool idea sorry I started
playing with it that afternoon the
testament to this is that this is really
easy to do I'm only going to show you
like 10 to 15 lines of code for every
app and it really is that easy if you do
want to do something fancier which I
talked at the last slide I do
ooofff authentication then maybe Kyle is
the person and hello as a person to talk
to but to get to start up and start it
it's really quite easy alright let's get
started okay so I'm just gonna all right
I'm just illustrating
there we go another app that I have
already so everyone does two plus two to
make sure the mathematical works I never
understood that so I could in an app
that does that adds 3 to a number so
we're gonna add 3 to 10 and hopefully
that comes back with 13 excellent
everything seems to be working
also if I if I do this I also have this
sort of help thing which is the option
arguments at the number to be added to
three stuff like that so we can we can
code all these so how do we go about
doing something like this so essentially
what the slash command does is it just
sends an HTTP POST to specific URL that
we're gonna specify and that post has a
particular payload and the payload looks
something like this it has a token a
team ID a domain but the more important
feels that were the ones I'll be talking
about today are sort of the text
the the response coil which is where we
need to send information back to slack
and maybe your username if you do
something with that so sort of the first
step is to figure out how to read the
payload the slide gives us so this is
HTTP request data which pretty much can
either read the body or the tokens of
the HTTP request if you do HTTP requests
form rules I'll give you everything back
so here I wrap I'm gonna be making this
Sora modularly
I wrap inactive because it or delayed
because if I were not to do that
it hasn't received an HTTP request to
performing these operations okay so
that's sort of just the bare bones of
how we're gonna go about reading the
payload that slide gives okay and like I
said the two things we really care about
is the text field and the response URL
so the text field is everything that
comes after the first space of the slash
command so you do add three space
whatever it is you want to do that gets
parsed as a single string that you can
then manipulate and do whatever your
code would do and there's a response URL
again
if I make this information that gets
back from the HTTP whether there's an
association I can just extract the text
field really easily there's really
nothing fancy happening right here okay
and now we're gonna try and perform some
computation so let's see if we can try
and code this slack app in real time so
I'm gonna for my computation I'm gonna
do this which is a super easy way to get
any text to compute in the Wolfram
language to say I want to do the
standard two plus two as a string it
gets interpreted with the interpreter as
an expression and then Wolfram language
it doesn't you don't particularly to
talk about this but it's sort of a
workaround okay so we have something
like this so we can even have you know
something like integrate X let's do
something looks slightly more
interesting because I X sure let's do
this so any string can then be parses of
the
wolfram expression so that's pretty much
what we're doing we're reading the text
we're passing it into this interpreter
and then we're making the result be a
string so they can be get parsed back
into the app and this is pretty much the
entire app or that list of computation I
guess behind it the next thing that we
ought to do is that we need to figure
out how to send it back to slack so the
same way we got we got an HTTP GET now
we're going to reply to that slack URL
with an HTTP POST so an express a JSON
formatted file with some set fields the
most important one is text where you put
your result and then there's other it
feels like the response type you can set
it to ephemeral so that it only appears
on the user they did it or you can also
if you were to do this in channel it
will appear for everyone okay and then
finally now that we have our and this
could be an export form or a string but
it has to be exported somehow as
adjacent once we have this we need
somewhere to store this on a server
somewhere so they can accept the HTTP
request and enter the Wolfram cloud
which is indeed very convenient for our
needs because in this simple line I just
this is the function that we were just
coding which just reads the HTTP request
pulls out the text does this little
computation using interpreter formats
the output as a JSON and then this it
just puts it up on the cloud the
importance of delayed here is that we
only want to perform this calculation
when every time rather slack would sort
of send one of these HTTP requests to
our website all right so let's do this
and now I need to copy this address and
then go over to slack I'm gonna go to my
apps over here okay I already had it
open so this is the absent there's
really easy to make I just made one that
says Wolfram technology 2018 yeah you
can go to slash commands and you'll see
I already have a couple of the ad threes
the one I showed you so we're just going
to do add new command we're gonna call
this slash
automatic input the request URL is
exactly that URL that it has to get
received that description needs a short
description alright and then we're all
set we're gonna save this and that
should do it
and if we now go over here we now have
whoops this new thing mathematical input
and if I were to do two plus two
hopefully you should come back as four
can also do Mathematica input again this
integrate command and that should also
come back so super easy to do four or
five lines and then we get most of the
flexibility of the Wolfram language or
computation that we can run in the cloud
I should say of course this gets parsed
as a string but we can use the
interpreter to do things like plot if I
were to convert this as a string you
will just read it as a graphics 3d we
could go the route of Mathematica one
and do this as a c---eight we could also
just rasterize this picture put it up
somewhere on the cloud and then attach
and then add an attachment to the
message that we send so there's just
another form that goes into our jason um
would you back and i that i do the text
saying graphics was also attached and i
had an attachment which has an image URL
which again is the result that we just
created exported into the web so i'm
gonna meet now i'm gonna use this one
instead you go back to slack and we're
gonna let's see I mean I changed this
guy now to this new URL and if
everything worked now we should have
Mathematica input let's see a lot 3d
more this way
please enter a relative expression or
just use this result
hmm what I'm that doesn't seem to work
excuse me oh no I think it should I
think this is still a graphics isn't
okay interesting
all right so let's do it's at that
thanks Kyle
okay
all right so then we get back the result
as an attachment okay so that was sort
of this super easy coding it on this on
the fly to get motion at least some of
the functionality of the command line of
Mathematica why is this useful well this
is one example that it was or the way I
started thinking about this in my lab so
we have this sort of local library of
books that we use in our lab mostly
physics ebooks and then these books are
either loaned out to some people or not
and you wanted to have this interface
where you can check which books are
available whether you can check out a
book stuff like that so we just made a
couple of different commands to do this
one is sort of the enquire command I
thought this was pretty funny you can
get some really funny loading messages
from the SimCity app in case you were
wondering stories like please wait your
ah critizing bureaucracies or some way
around
please wait asserting pact exemplars
these are pretty funny loading messages
but then the actual code is again not
entirely complex I mean it looks a bit
long because I'm adding sort of some
useful help text so what what the user
should do if there was an error and some
error catching stuff like that and then
here is just me parsing that string and
then finally again sending the result
back as a rasterized image one thing to
note is that slack expects an original
HTTP reply in the first three seconds
three or five seconds which what that
means is that if some of your
combinations expect you expect them to
take longer than that so the thing
doesn't timeout you usually first have
to send an original HTTP request sort of
somehow informing the slack that you've
received that and everything's okay but
also somehow telling your user then
everything's fine I'm just loading your
message and that's sort of where the
loading messages come in so we do this
using URL submit which is asynchronous
and then we can continue doing our
entire computation and then again once
we have a result send back this URL
submit asynchronously to slack so slack
allows it it requires us in the first
three minutes but in a lot it gives you
a window of 30 minutes
- for that URL as actives and sent
anything back okay so what are we gonna
do here we're gonna do Bibb Inquirer I'm
just gonna see I want to see all the
books and I want to see the author's the
title let's say the status of them
please rate relaxing splines okay and
then we get back our data set that says
that these are the books that we have in
our library these are the authors and
these are the statuses of the book I
mean I can go further than that and say
alright I'm actually you want to check
out this book which is called which
title is the physics of phonons it's
actually what I work on so if anyone has
anything to contribute to the physics of
phonons I would be really happy to learn
to hear and I want you to borrow whoa
all right well I'm not entirely sure why
it says it didn't work because it made
it work well that's what happens when
you do live coding right but if I were
to go back and check my library now I
think it ought to say that that book has
been checked out by me database Q is
equal to true
okay so that book was successfully
loaned out to G varna V this is sort of
the slack username so that's another one
of those tests or those fields that get
sparse as the payload and it
automatically assigned it to me I mean
this is sort of a simple example that we
found useful in my lab and then I think
a last thing that is presumably of
interest is okay that's the borrower a
new command but what if we want to
interact with data so it's really quite
common when you're in a slack
workstation to be sort of uploading text
files with data sort of exchanging with
your collaborators and it would be great
if we could somehow have access to that
data to visualize like I said this is
cheating because I'm going to create a
I'm gonna upload create a public URL to
do this but the actual API does sort of
provide this over the authentication if
we wanted to go down that route left
doesn't exercise to the reader okay the
code is here so you don't want to say
anything about the code no really it's
the idea is that are just gonna take the
link and it's going to reformat the link
to the route it to the address that I
oughta downloaded and then it will
execute that URL downloading the data
and I'm just gonna list plus the data
then pass it back again as an attachment
so the way that would work over here is
that I could come over here and say I
want to add let's see what I have in my
documents as example data dot M X so now
I've added it to slack I'm gonna come
over here I'm gonna say create external
link copy that address and then I'm
gonna do visualize data link copy paste
and the name of the file is example data
dot and thanks and then we get back the
result happening getting let's plot it
with Mathematica this is a particular
example from the list plot Help section
right like I said like all of these the
actual link and the exactly the name
could be automated and curls you can
also have events where every time a user
uploads something
it sort of triggers this event on the
app and then it says okay something is
being uploaded get the token do the
OAuth authentication and then pass the
you can transfer data back and forth but
this was all an afternoon could spare me
yeah I think I'm gonna stop there unless
there's any questions yeah excuse me so
everything that I've shown is in this
notebook which I've given to the to the
presenter ready people so I'm guessing
uploaded and passable if not I can add
my file to pass it
you mean in the form of a package or
something and I'm not entirely sure it's
that sophisticated I could but it's
really it's really quite easy to get
these started in the these ten lines
that are in the notebook right yeah I
mean ideally one if you if you were to
create a link for this you would want to
go down the the bought route to do this
authentication so you can have a sort of
this wolfram bought that's sitting on
slag and every time you want to interact
with you do at Wolfram bot visualize
data for me send data to add Kyle or
something like this and that can be done
but yeah it has not uh yeah actually
yesterday I was debugging this to some
extent with Craig and yeah you can send
it either to a different channel or so
here I was sending it to Craig I could
also send it to a particular channel and
like I said this is also the where the
FML and the in Channel things come in so
for this one the the text that I gave it
or the instruction is in channel meaning
that it prints also the command and the
person I did it and then the result
whereas if we were to do something like
add three this is FM Errol which means
that it's
just gonna come back with their answer
and there's no and this old would only
appear to me so if I were to do it in
the channel with Craig this will not
appear I think actually I might get only
visible to you so you can figure out who
your commands are visible to well that's
more of like a draft space where you can
do notes yeah but I do talk to myself
quite a lot right so if I were to go
here on my apps these are so in the
settings for the apps there you can set
authentications and permissions for
particular users but by the default when
you install it at a particular channel
everyone takes gets sort of the same
authorship of this so the authorization
of this haphazard can confirm user
entity I can add slash commands and it
can access the workspace files
ah so in this particular workstation so
anyone that has access to this
workstation can go so in this particular
workstation it's quite boring it's just
me and Craig in this particular
workstation but in other way stations
for example my lab there is on the order
of 15 20 people and all of them can then
access that particular command just just
to make sure that yeah
yeah and you can have guests at
particular channels like you only allow
them access to this particular channel
and they can only see these things so
there's quite a bit of flexibility so
for example right I was I pushed up this
application and then I was testing it
and then Craig comes in and does the
same command it works for him sort of
out of the box as well so anyone that
has access to that channel
um well she doesn't particularly know
well she doesn't know that I'm here but
like I said this I wasn't kidding in my
and this wasn't some sort of me patting
myself on the back this was one
afternoons work so I think she'll be
okay with it
hey I made a library for the lab come on
okay well I'll be here as well until
Friday so feel free to catch me thank
you